what happens when a mother and a
daughter set out on a 2000 mile trek
on the appalachian trail just two weeks
before a pandemic hits
well they keep on trucking and they
finish that bad boy and here
to tell us all about their amazing
journey please welcome brianna
and camber sullivan mothers and
daughters
[Applause]
oh my god okay so you i have my
daughters here today so i love mothers
and daughters
it's like it's everything it's my
emotional achilles heel from my own past
and
my journey and destiny here on earth
mothers and daughters okay you traveled
2 000 miles all on your own four feet
how did you do this yeah well
we we actually i was very interested
in nature and getting back out into it
and reconnecting
and i heard about the appalachian trail
but i thought you know my kids are young
i won't be able to do this for quite a
while and that's where
camber became the catalyst for this year
and making it happen
yeah about a year before we left i was
on the internet
and i found this amazing thing called
the appalachian trail
it was a six month journey and a very
long block
and i told myself i need to do it and so
i went up to my mom and i was like
next year we're doing that and you did
okay
and so can you talk to my daughters
uh after like we finished this segment
camber thank you okay sorry go on i'm
very i'm like
i know i it was so incredible because to
prove that she could do this she trained
for a half marathon and she worked out
all of the stats and said we can do this
we can do 13 miles a day and we'll
finish if we start march first and end
august 22nd we can do this and
not only did we do that 13 mile days but
we ended up having a 48 mile
day because it just it happened she
was so positive and she just made it
happen
wow frankie and i took a walk around our
neighborhood today i guess that really
doesn't compare
uh i mean how you know
you are so inspiring to young
ladies out there really because you know
olive went to the skate park
this weekend and you know we're always
trying to find
ways to be physical and i mean this is
you know you are a real inspiration this
is just
incredible i think you should teach a
ted talk and a master class right now to
young ladies out there
what is your advice to try and try
something like this
you you really have to know what you're
in for
you really gotta understand that you
will be waking up every day and you will
be walking
and it might be monotonous but you gotta
know
that you can make it through and that
you will make it to the end
yeah and i think having positive outlook
and always keeping a positive mentality
and thinking a better thought
is really what got us through and helped
us to maintain
our stamina and our desire
i mean honestly it is hard to ask you
questions because my jaw is just
on the table right here i'm i'm so
inspired by what we do
by the way i heard you uh brought your
guitar
i did i think that it is super important
to um keep the positivity going and to
make sure that you're not bored from the
monotonous routine
of just getting up and hiking every day
with a big pack on your back
and camber were you into the guitar or
like a month in were you like
ear pods in and nodding like i
love the guitar i thought it was the
most amazing
thing like so many people would just
come up to us and be like oh my god is
that a guitar
and it was just amazing to have somebody
as cool as my mom
you know bringing this amazing skill on
trail and it was just it was amazing
as the mother of two daughters i'm going
to carry
you both in my heart and try and funnel
the inspiration into our family
truly brianna and camber thank you so
much
for being here
[Music]